one of the things I noticed throughout
my career and the things that I found
actually quite distressing was the way
bullying changed and metamorphosize
especially when it came to social media
bullying on social media and I
personally think social media is not
what most damaging influences on our
young children especially on girls then
it is on boys
because the amount of bullying
horrendous the messages that I used to
see which I found upsetting and they
weren't even directed at me yeah yeah so
we have a major issue at school about
social media so that's the one place so
bullying in the school doesn't happen
but it will happen on social media and
but what's great is that you cannot be
involved in that if you don't have a
smartphone right and we have a huge push
we have we give digital detox events to
the parents where parents are invited
and I talked them through the dangers of
social media and the smartphones my
advice to all parents is do not give
your child a smartphone not until
they're 16 possibly even 18 and that
again is controversial people think but
why would you do that children free they
should be able to do what they like well
you can do that there was one young man
not at our school who was it with with
tech posting certain things on YouTube
insulted a South London gang he was
knifed to death there are other children
I could tell you about who they get
involved in criminal activity they get
involved in gang activity because they
meet these people through unsupervised
access to the Internet and that's what
the smartphone gives you unsupervised
access to the Internet and we want we
once used to put the porn magazines on
the top shelf in the shops nowadays well
you give yourself give me child
smartphone they can access porn they can
access gambling they can do anything
they like on there and parents are a lot
less tech-savvy than are there their
children and so children are running
rings around their parents my big advice
is do not give them a smartphone if you
do the iPhone for instance has all sorts
of controls on there where you can put a
password and you can block certain sites
snapchat Instagram whatsapp they are
toxic you need to get off there when you
look at what the way in which children
will talk to each other the bullying
that goes on the swearing that the it's
just it's absolutely dreadful not to
mention the way in which they were
use technology just to take pictures of
each other's homework never really do
their work you are undermining your
child massively if you give them a
smartphone it's really really
interesting that you say that because
you know like we were talking about with
the bullying element of it and the gangs
how big a problem is gangs at the moment
in London because the average person
picks up their copy of the imaging
standard and they will see you know
another boy stabbed to death
tragic where do you see the gang problem
in London how bad is it
and is it worse and we actually think is
I don't know if it's worse I mean of
course we do a very good job I'm not the
best person to talk to in a way because
our children we do such a good job of
protecting them that they and they don't
necessarily have that the typical
experience of of children elsewhere
we're persuading parents to give up
smartphones we're persuading parents to
pick them up after school or etc etc
sometimes you know we have issues but um
I don't know if it's worse I mean there
is a problem there's a problem there are
so many problems there are so many
issues that children come up against
like you were talking about girls for
instance on social media if you allow
your child to have a smartphone and it's
a she's a girl all she understands about
her self-worth is you got to make
yourself look four five years older you
got to pout your lips and stick your
bottom out and make yourself look really
sexy because that's all you're worth the
idea of being a powerful woman one day
and running your own business or being a
lawyer or whatever it is they that
doesn't exist in that world it's really
it's it's really frightening and what
I'm always trying to get across to
parents and I do the same on Twitter and
so on is uh
don't fool yourself parents they'll some
people who arguably say I trust my child
okay you know fine I could tell you
about poor Brett bednar who at 14 years
old was gaming with his friends there
was one boy in the gaming ring that his
mother didn't know she was a wonderful
mother you know she used to do baby
swimming with him when he was a baby and
all this um and then there was this
about the boy in over two years
he was gradually groomed you know and he
loved this boy and thought he was so
brilliant and one day this boy sent him
money to get into a cab went to his
house was tied to a chair with duct tape
and had his throat slit now if his
mother had not allowed him unsupervised
access to the Internet that boy would be
alive today and what happens I could
tell you about Kaylee I could tell you
about Molly the other day who sadly
committed suicide because of all the
self-harm images she was sent by via
Instagram and via um it may been
snapchat actually I don't want to I
don't know which one it was it was one
of them and Pinterest kept on sending
these these images and even though you
try and get off these images you can't
because the algorithms are such that the
more you click on them the more they
keep sending you and parents don't know
Molly's parents didn't know and then
they say every time this happens parents
make a video they make some video about
it to warn other parents they say please
listen to me listen to what I'm saying
nobody watches these videos right so I
show this to my parents and I say you
know listen you know listen to what I'm
saying you're putting your child's life
in danger now that's the worst end of it
then there's just the point pop point of
well what about their GCSEs you know so
many of them are addicted so they can't
get off their smartphone when they're
working at night and they're saying to
us please miss help me my mom isn't home
because she's working three jobs
she can't take the phone away from me
what do I do I'm addicted and I can't
get ready for my GCSEs it's a major
problem and I genuinely think that the
smartphone will increase the division
between the poor and the rich because
it's the rich who argue with me and who
constantly say to me on Twitter oh but
my child is firing what are you talking
about and I'm telling you because
they're at home they have the nannies
and the tutors and they're able to
monitor their child's use of social
media and what they don't understand is
that those ideas filter through
especially when journalists so I was i
spoke to Toby young recently and I was
telling him off for for saying that
fortnight was okay because he writes
about these things and I said you are a
talking head and you have responsibility
you cannot talk about this stuff because
actually your boys probably gonna be
fine but what happens is those ideas
trickle down to my families and we at
school are struggling on the ground the
people who support me 100% on Twitter
when I say this stuff at teachers
because the teachers get it they see it
and I'm telling you in 20 years there
will be controls on
they will be giving out warnings just
like they do for cigarettes and alcohol
and driving and getting married and
having sex all of these things are
banned to children and I'm telling you I
was just thinking about it on the on the
tube on the way here today I was
watching all these people on their
phones and I was thinking isn't it
interesting how Steve Jobs has given
this extraordinary thing to people and
he's not here to see just how damaging
it is
[Music]